for 11 years he hosted one of the most
popular art shows on television
transforming a blank canvas to a
finished painting in a remarkably short
30 minutes he captivated audiences with
his mesmerizing voice and his relaxed
demeanor and of course his signature
poem
nearly 25 years after his death the
painter of happy little trees is
immortalized through internet memes
inspirational quotes a thriving business
in his name and reruns of the show the
dry of painting his fame as a
pop-culture icon shows no sign of
diminishing yet so little is known about
his life today on biographic sui piece
together the world of bob ross beyond
the canvas bob ross was fiercely private
and never revealed details of his
personal life he gave very few
interviews claiming no one bothered to
ask him looking for answers is
especially difficult considering that no
official biography of his life exists
from primary sources the one documentary
bob ross the happy painter can only be
obtained by pledging money to PBS or
getting a hold of a DVD copy the book
happy clouds happy trees the Bob Ross
phenomenon admitted that their text is
about an understanding we have of Bob
Ross and his life if we had wanted to
write an accurate biographical book on
Bob Ross that goal would be difficult to
accomplish
adding to the elusive Ross he was said
to have very few friends and they out of
respect only ever conducted interviews
for the aforementioned documentary that
is not readily or widely available facts
are hard to come by and nearly
impossible to verify still some
specifics are known and so far remain
undisputed so here's what we know Robert
Bob Norman Ross was born on October the
29th 1942 in Daytona Beach Florida to
Jack a builder and carpenter and Ally a
waitress when Ross was just a year and a
half old his parents divorced and Ross
moved to Orlando not much is known of
Ross's childhood in Orlando save for two
defining moments as a freshman in high
school Ross wanted to drop out in order
to work as a carpenter alongside his
father around this same time Ross
suffered an accident losing the tip of
his left Indian
finger on a sawblade Ross must have been
self-conscious about his deformed hand
for the rest of his life on his hit
television show the joy of painting Ross
carefully disguised it halting his paint
palette so that it remained shielded
from view most of the time
Ross was known to be an animal lover his
entire life as a youngster this may have
been passed on from his mother as a
teenager
Ross allegedly kept exotic pets
including armadillos and alligators
later on in his life his pet gray
squirrel sometimes made an appearance on
his television show Ross once said if
we're going to have animals around we
all have to be concerned about them and
take care of them Bob Ross married twice
during his life and had three sons he
married his first wife Linda Brown early
on in his military career and they
divorced in 1981 the couple had two sons
Bob jr. and Steven Steven would follow
in his father's footsteps and became a
certified Bob Ross painting instructor
Ross's second wife Jane was a civilian
in Alaska they had one son Morgan who
would also become an accomplished artist
sadly Jane died from cancer in 1993 and
Ross did not remarry
[Music]
long before his time on public
television Ross was in the military at
the age of 18 Ross joins the United
States Air Force and within a few years
he was uprooted from his native Florida
and sent to an entirely unfamiliar place
Fairbanks Alaska Ross spent the next 20
years of his life in Alaska working
raising a family and developing a love
of painting amid the majestic mountains
towering Pines and crystal-clear waters
examining Ross's paintings over his
lifetime one can see without question
the trees Peaks valleys and streams are
distinctly Alaskan eventually Ross rose
through the Air Force ranks do master
sergeants after holding positions as a
medical records technician and first
sergeant of the clinic at Ulsan Air
Force Base these positions required him
to be in his own words tough and mean he
was the guy who makes you scrub the
latrine the guy who makes you make your
bed the guy who screams at you for being
late to work ross gained reputation for
being hard on his subordinates who
nicknamed him bust him up Bobby for
anyone who has watched Ross on the Dry
of painting the image of him as this
authoritarian military figure couldn't
be further from his television
personality
apparently Ross yelled so much during
his military career he never wanted to
raise his voice again after he left the
Air Force
Ross's first brush with painting
occurred as an art class at the
Anchorage USO Club but he clashed with
his abstract loving instructors
according to Ross they failed to teach
him the practical techniques of how to
paint that tell you what makes a tree
but they wouldn't tell you how to paint
a tree fortunately he experienced and
turn him away from painting altogether
Ross soon found a more suitable painting
instructor on public television
Ross's predecessor was an older German
painter named Bill Alexander he hosted a
half-hour instructional painting show
the magic of oil painting on PBS
watching the show Ross learns how to
paint in the alert Prima style this is
Italian for first attempts also known in
the art world as wet-on-wet Ross
perfected the technique which allowed
him to complete a finished work in a
single session
unlike other painting methods when an
artist uses a la prima he or she can add
wet paint in layers without waiting for
the paint to fully dry
Alexander falsely claims to have
invented the star but it actually dates
back to the 15th century in Flanders
which is modern-day Belgium Alla Prima
was popular with many famous artists
throughout history but enjoyed great
fanfare among the impressionist painters
in the 19th century notably it was a
favorite technique of artists Claude
Monet and John Singer Sargent after
further honing his skills Ross decided
to supplement his Air Force pay by
selling landscapes painted on the inside
of gold prospecting pans to tourists it
was a lucrative endeavor iran's when his
earnings from painting surpassed his
military salary he resigns to become a
full-time artist
[Music]
upon leaving the airforce Ross returned
to Florida and sought out bill Alexander
in order to perfect his painting skills
by that time Alexander taught art
classes in his spare time and happily
took on the eager Ross Alexander didn't
realize that Ross would later take
everything he got from these lessons
make his own show and rise to the level
of superstardom he did this actually
eventually led to the two men falling
out during the early meetings Alexander
was impressed with Ross and he hired him
as a traveling tutor for the Alexander
magic art supplies company at the same
time 900 miles away from Alexander
studio in Clearwater Florida
a woman named Annette Kowalski was
experiencing a debilitating depression
after losing her oldest son in a traffic
accident unable to get up she laid in
bed all day watching television episodes
of the magic foil painting desperate and
hoping to cheer his wife up Walter
kowalski signed a net up for a five-day
painting class with Alexander or so she
thought before Annette's arrival
Alexander had passed on his classes to
an unknown instructor known simply as
Bob and Ed was incredibly disappointed
when she heard Alexander was no longer
instructing but Walter insisted that she
go anyway saying get in the car
we're going over the course of the
five-day painting class whatever
misgivings Annette first had about Ross
completely disappeared in fact taking
that class she realized there was
something very special about him looking
back years later a net said I was so
mesmerized by Bob somehow he lifted me
out of that depression I just think that
Bob knew how to woo people well ruling
people that was kind of Ross's calling
card and that was on to something and
she saw in Ross an opportunity to put it
in a bottle and sell it
she believed Ross was capable of making
a fortune and she wanted in after the
class and out and our husbands took Ross
out to dinner and brokered a business
deal
from that point on Annette became Ross's
manager sinking her entire life savings
into the partnership Ross and his wife
pointed up a similar amount of capital
as manager Manette focused on taking out
ads in the local papers and setting up
painting seminars at various malls she
even established a toll-free telephone
hotline 1-800 Bob Ross but for people to
really connect and experience the allure
of Bob Ross she needed to get him in
front
of as many people as possible they
filmed a commercial and possibly a pilot
television show in order to sell it to
PBS executives eventually all the hard
work and hustle paid off and Ross landed
his own show on the network for joy of
painting the first episode aired on
January the 11th 1983 the joy of
painting enjoyed an 11-year run on PBS
from 1983 to 1994 filming four hundred
and three episodes in total during the
30 minutes of air time for each show
Ross stood in a dark room with a blank
canvas and painted an imaginary
landscape scene there were two cameras
for the program shot in real time a
medium shot of Ross and his canvas and
take close-up shot of the canvas or the
palette
Ross faithfully instructed oil painting
to viewers at home in the alah premise
style the same technique he previously
learned from Bill Alexander with little
more than smudges blotches and scrapes
from his palace knife
Ross created masterpieces to keep the
lessons inexpensive for people the tools
and color selection was limited though
he surely had the technique down Ross's
real draw for Ian's sirs was his calming
presence slower paced speech warm voice
and words of encouragement sprinkled in
while instructing in this way Ross is
often compared to Fred Rogers the iconic
children's show host of Mister Rogers
neighborhood on the drive painting there
was no pressure from Ross he believed
everyone could paint almighty pictures
and there are no mistakes
only happy accidents the joy of painting
proved to be an immediate success for
the PBS network for some viewers it was
a reprieve from the harsh realities of
life or the doldrums of other television
programs when asked about his consoling
approach Ross said I got a letter from
somebody here a while back
and they said Bob everything in your
world seems to be happy that's for sure
that's why I paint it's because I can
create the kind of world that I want and
I can make this world as happy as I want
it shoot if you want bad stuff watch the
news the joy of painting was like a
personal arts lesson described by his
manager Annette as liquid tranquilizer
yes amazingly only about 10% of viewers
painted along with Ross the other 90%
tuned in do simply watch him Ross worked
quickly to create his masterpieces
swirling the paint around dabbing ads
here and there and grabbing for his
two-inch brush every now and then and
now let's get crazy he made the whole
process of painting look completely
effortless
the truth is that Ross was meticulous
and his manager Annette referred to him
as a tyrant Ross was not mean or nasty
according to Annette but he was every
bit as much a businessman as he was a
painter he wanted everything on the show
to be perfect and done his way before
filming each episode Ross with lay awake
at night planning and rehearsing exactly
what he would say no one watching will
ever know Ross always appeared to be
calm and freeform on camera his planning
extended to more than the words he said
though for each episode of the drive
painting Ross didn't complete just one
painting he always finished three Ross
painted one while filming the one
everyone saw and other was done
before--and Santa just off camera for
rsti use as a reference and the final
painting the more detailed work was
completed after the show and was
photographed for use in Ross's
instruction books Ross was never
actually paid for appearing in any of
the shows on PBS instead he used it to
promote his teaching business this
worked spectacularly and interest in it
expanded after just the first episode
the business Bob Ross Inc eventually
grew to include paint supplies branded
by Bob Ross and the company and Ross
raked in millions of dollars to further
bring his brand into the spotlight
Ross occasionally appeared on talk show
hasn't appeared in promotional gigs some
of these included MTV the Joan Rivers
show Phil Donahue and as a guest at a
Hank's no country music concert the
final dry of paintings show aired on May
the 17th 1994 after Ross was diagnosed
with cancer
Ross's son Steven who made regular
appearances on the show appeared with
his father on the set
[Music]
most of rasa's image was intentionally
created except for his trademark afro
believe it or not his hair wasn't even
naturally curly it was straight before
he officially had made it
Ross ditched his short military crew
cuts for a longer style and perm as a
way to save money once his perm was a
hallmark of the Bob Ross brand he
couldn't bring himself to change it even
though he grew to dislike it later after
Ross got sick from lymphoma cancer and
lost all his hair to chemotherapy
treatments he wore a wig on it's showed
to keep up his appearance
Ross's outfits were another carefully
crafted element of his look on the DR
painting Ross wore casual blue jeans
with a button-up shirt the top buttons
were left undone to reveal a bit of
chest out this timeless look was
intended to appear currents when PBS
aired reruns of the show later on a
private man Ross and his manager and S
told a back story of a life that was
light on biographical details the story
emphasized modest beginnings a love of
nature and animals and a philosophy that
every person matters his caring
personality extended to his viewers
students and injured animals that he
took in and cared for this narrative
continues to be pushed today by the
business Bob Ross Inc
in 1994 Ross was dealt a devastating
blow with his diagnosis of lymphoma a
rare type of cancer lymphoma is in a
group of blood cancers it attacks the
lymphatic system the lymph nodes and
glands along with a network of vessels
are an important part of the body's
circulatory functions that aid in a
person's immune system many people with
lymphoma never have or display symptoms
and it isn't known how much Ross
suffered from his disease Ross kept his
cancer diagnosis out of the public eye
only telling his closest friends and
relatives he apparently painted right up
until the end and died in 1995 at the
age of 52 at his grave at Woodlands
Memorial Park in Florida a simple stone
marker reads Bob Ross television artist
Bob brass was a prolific artist
purportedly completing at 30,000
paintings during his lifetime with so
many Ross paintings out there in the
world it would seem relatively easy to
find one and buy it in order to hang it
above a living room couch but this is
not true anyone wanting to purchase one
today would be hard-pressed to find an
original the reason for this is because
there are so many copycat and
four-diamond versions that have flooded
the market place further virtually all
of Ross's paintings made on the joy of
painting have been donated to PBS
fundraisers to raise money for other
public broadcasting programs today the
company bob ross inc is still going
strong and is still managed by annette
and walter kowalski the company sells a
variety of paints brushes art kits
easels canvases instructional DVDs and
books on their website one can find and
order Bob Ross branded apparel including
socks t-shirts and baby bibs there are
an array of accessories and wacky gifts
including coffee mugs glasses even a
certified Bob Ross chia pet beyond the
official merchandise one can find just
about anything with the Bob Ross image a
quick google search even returns a
prayer candle named for Saint bob ross
bob Ross's company it still trains and
certifies painting instructors who
desire to work teach and promote
themselves in the spirit of the artist
most recently Netflix as licensed shows
adding Bob Ross's series beauty is
everywhere and the joy of painting to
its lineup in pop culture references to
Bob Ross Santos aphorisms are everywhere
his likeness and inspirational quotes
live on through internet memes Google
celebrated Ross / what would have been
his 70th birthday in 2012 with a Google
doodle an image of Ross painting the
letter G with a landscape in the
background
he has been mentioned in many popular
television shows such as Family Guy in
the boondocks Target stores even carry a
Bob Ross board game called
Bob Ross the art of chill if all of this
wasn't enough the Lego company has
created a bob ross lego figure complete
with a paintbrush and palette his icon
status today shows absolutely no signs
of diminishing it seems Ross's legacy is
never going to die and his fans will
continue to honor and celebrate the man
for years to come
Ross once said didn't you know you
hadn't that much power you can move
mountains you can do anything
he showed us he could create a better
place a world filled with happy little
trees that was free of judgments
where everyone was an artist and every
landscape was full of majestic wonder so
I really hope you enjoyed that episode
of biographic s-- if you did there's a
couple of things you could do right now
one is hit that like button below also
if you want more stuff like this we put
out brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching